Here's a list of the kinds of
data that must be collected.
The reason for some of these should
be clear from our prior discussions.
Smoking status, to help prevent
the development of chronic disease.
Maintaining an active medication list,
to avoid duplicate or
inappropriate medications.
Performing a drug formulary check,
to make sure the best
available medication is chosen for
each clinical situation.
And maintaining a current problem list.
So that each provider has
a more complete overview
of what's going on in
their patients care.
Keep this list in mind,
as we later discuss meaningful use.
The EHR usage requirements
placed on eligible providers.